what advice would you give to Young
Folks today you know operating in um
in this complicated space about how to
have a successful life a life they can
be proud of a career they can be proud
of
maybe somebody in high school in college
thinking about what they're going to do
be a hacker you know if you have any
interest become a hacker
and apply yourself to defense you know
every time like we do have these these
amazing scholarship programs for
instance where you know they find you
early they'll pay your college as long
as you commit to some kind of federal
commitment to sort of help federal
agencies with cyber security and where
does everyone want to go every year from
the scholarship program they want to go
work at the NSA or cyber command you
know they want to go work on offense
they want to go do the sexy stuff it's
really hard to get people to work on
defense it's just it's always been more
fun to be a pirate than be in the Coast
Guard you know and so
we have a huge deficit when it comes to
filling those roles there's 3.5 million
unfilled cyber security positions around
the world I mean talk about job security
like be a hacker and work on cyber
security you will always have a job
um and we're actually had a huge deficit
and disadvantage as a free market
economy
um because we can't match cyber security
salaries at palantir or Facebook or
Google or Microsoft and so it's really
hard for the United States to fill those
roles
um and you know other countries have had
this work round where they basically
have forced conscription on some level
you know China tells people like you do
whatever you're gonna do during the day
work at Alibaba you know if you need to
do some ransomware okay but the minute
we tap you on the shoulder and ask you
to come do this sensitive operation for
us the answer is yes
um you know same with Russia you know a
couple years ago when Yahoo was hacked
and they laid it all out in an
indictment it came down to two cyber
criminals and two guys from the FSB
cyber criminals were allowed to have
their fun but the minute they came
across the username and password for
someone's personal Yahoo account that
worked at the White House or the state
department or military they were
expected to pass that over to the FSB so
we don't do that here and it's it's even
worse on defense we really can't fill
these positions so you know be if if you
are a hacker or if you're interested in
code if you're a tinker you know learn
how to hack
um there are all sorts of amazing
hacking competitions you can do through
the Sans org for example San s
uh and then use those skills for good
you know neuter the bugs in that code
that get used by autocratic regimes to
make people's life you know a living
prison
um you know plug those holes you know
defend Industrial Systems defend our
water treatment facilities from hacks
where people are trying to come in and
poison the water you know that I think
is just an amazing
um it's an amazing job on so many levels
it's intellectually stimulating you can
tell yourself you're serving your
country you can tell yourself you're
saving lives and keeping people safe and
you'll always have amazing job security
and if you need to go get that job that
pays you you know two million bucks a
year you can do that too and you can
have a public profile more so of a
public profile you can be a public rock
star I mean it's the same thing as uh
sort of the military there's a lot of
um
there's a lot of uh well-known sort of
people commenting on the fact that
veterans are not treated as well as they
should be but it's still the fact that
soldiers are deeply respected for for uh
defending the country the freedoms the
the ideals that we stand for and in the
same way I mean in some ways this the
cyber security defense are the soldiers
of the future yeah and you know it's
interesting I mean in in cyber security
the difference is oftentimes you see the
more interesting threats in the private
sector because that's where the attacks
come you know when when cyber criminals
and nation-state adversaries come for
the United States they don't go directly
for cyber command or the NSA no they go
for banks they go for a Google they go
for Microsoft they go for critical
infrastructure and so those companies
those private sector companies get to
see some of the most advanced
sophisticated attacks out there and you
know if you're working at FireEye and
you're calling out the solar winds
attack for instance I mean you just
saved God knows how many systems from
you know that compromise turning into
something that more closely resembles
sabotage
um so you know go go be a hacker and or
go be a journalist